il valait light m bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
avec plus de 4400 d'essai pour 11
millions d'habitants la belgique a le
plus fort taux de mortalité lié au
corona virus en europe comment est-ce
que vous l'expliquer il ya différentes
explications de gaza
ça c'est que le pays a choisi depuis le
début de le comptabiliser en aucun cas
provisoirement l'entièreté les décès au
bâti blanc récent de peau comme étant
que huit plus hauts d'emblée c'est comme
dans d'autres pays on n'a pas fait le
testing dans la maison pose certainement
au départ et donc c'est simplement basé
sur un tableau clinique de température
est de savoir ce qui fait qu'on a
peut-être et la moitié 2 essais son
temps mais son propos la moitié en
hôpital ce qui explique probablement la
différence
il a transmis dans lequel il faut être
positif ou être comptabilisé vous
parlais justement de ces tests ces
dépistages une façon de conter qui fait
débat dans le royaume la belgique qui
est intègre dans ses statistiques vous
l'avez dit les morts suspecté d'être lié
aux coville 19 et pas seulement celles
dont on a la certitude qu'elles sont
imputables au virus pourquoi ce choix
le choix était fait au départ à crosne
été dans l'impossibilité pour le
reconnais de tester dans les maisons de
hole ont limité de s il faisait
appliquer aux passants doivent être
hospitalisés dans les hôpitaux classique
et les maisons de repos n'ont pas été
testés sur testing commence maintenant
depuis une semaine
d'ailleurs les chiffres relativement
important de patients aussi
symptomatique qu'ils sont comptables
comment est ce que sont les hôpitaux en
ce moment en belgique est ce qu'ils sont
saturés notamment au service de
réanimation
la situation a pu être mal une nous
n'avons pas d'occupation des 2300 et
quel public qui étaient étaient au
public
nous sommes actuellement à 54 cents et
la situation est en train de lentement
normal mais très justement le retour à
la normale est prévu pour le 3 mai en
tous les cas c'est le retour peut-être à
la vie normale du côté de la belgique
même si aucun rassemblement public ne
sera autorisé avant
le 31 août mesures cohérentes ou
disproportionnée selon vous dans la
mesure tout à fait cohérent dans ses
gars belgique est un pays de festival
prenne en cinquante mille cent mille
cent cinquante mille personnes au nom du
monde entier de l'europe
en dehors du problème des frontières et
santé paho belle maison autant de monde
autant de jours site construite de l'eau
aurait été une véritable avait dans le
bouillant culture si on peut dire
pouvoir
on l'a dit à la date du 3 mai c'est le
confinement qui est prolongé jusque là
du côté de la belgique est ce qu'un
déconfinement progressif est vraiment
envisageable après cette date
comment est-ce qu'il va s'organiser
comment le gouvernement s'organiser
comment est il perçu par la population
et par le corps des médecins par rapport
à toutes ces mesures dans le 3 mai et
d'un totalement provisoire parfaitement
deux pas des confiné à partir du 3 mai
parce que au départ se basait affiliés
savoir que la cause de l'infection était
nettement descendant ce n'est peut-être
pas aussi plein sport deuxièmement
d'avoir une bonne idée de de la
population protéger son appel à
séroprévalence la population se doit
arrêter aucun weill en europe n'a lutté
et troisièmement d'avoir enfin ces deux
tests pour dépister plus nouveaux cas
ceux ci devraient être ceux ci devaient
être elle en effet donc si la situation
ne s'améliore pas ne pas des conflits
nés de parent mais la population est
bien sûr de man 2 pouvoir peut
s'échapper de l'intérieur même si les
limitations en france on peut se
promener on peut perdre et ordinaire la
population est aussi consciente ne peut
pas des conflits nés trop tôt parce
qu'on ça on risque à ce moment là une
deuxième pacte important d'équilibrer
fait relever le plafond de sécurité donc
selon vous la population belge en est
consciente mais ce qu'elle accepte et
et de votre côté dans votre secteur à
vous comment est ce que les médecins le
personnel soignant perçoit tout cela
personnel soignant et tout ce qui va se
passer parce que le deuxième vague alors
il ya beaucoup donné pendant trois
semaines il attend que le gouvernement
prenne des décisions seulement si c'est
possible la population psychologiquement
commence à montrer des signes du sud ans
est extrêmement ouvert le 2 temps de
l'été dans l appareil
il paie potter et les gens de sortir
donc on est un peu balancé entre on a
envie de faire autre chose mais on se
rend compte de notre côté que la
situation n'est pas complètement sous
contrôle et dont le 3 mai scandale et
peut-être pas là déconfinement le saura
dans huit jours puisque dans les jours à
nouveau conseillé de s'équiper des
doigts de donner plus d'informations
c'est mona fin merci à yves van laethem
d'avoir répondu à une question je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
responsable de la travel clinique du chu
saint-pierre de bruxelles